hello and welcome to this video playing
drama door just before yes okay what is
I'm doing you some been only here benoni
stuff I interesting and check benoni
with a six and 84 inserted yeah one day
I said a huge difference we'll see
probably not a huge difference but
that's okay we shall have 6 cm how do
you play this with why it's taking or
keeping the tension probably them and
keep the tension
let's see what he does if you check that
it doesn't take to e 8 okay i'm covering
seafoam this is something that could be
useful i will now i'll take and no light
takes doesn't come with the temple so
should be okay for me here Knight g4 is
that maybe not g4 is a bit of a nuisance
okay I'll cover this
okay how I am always so amazed how
quickly those most get played I came and
this is a this is I think very risky
because he takes away more defenders
from the nine squares but ok what's here
don't get me wrong I'm not saying it is
necessarily bad I'm just saying that
this is a very far-reaching decision
that was taken in a split second we'll
see probably it's not losing on time
that often this is the advantage of
course of playing those those super
important most immediately
so check here check yes it should be
somewhat dangerous him Wow look f6 Scott
okay 6 I don't just take it here right
wow wow wow wow
Wow and I didn't need a moment to kind
of compose myself and what is this
Knight f3 book takes Wow ok so i should
check look at shakespeare's you had take
their King tix but I didn't have a
follow-up check unfortunately rookie
five looks good summer and clean up to
yeah after after speed up now this was
the idea who gave aid as a big threat
oh wow if such heavy rainfall outside
you probably going to hear it on the
recording yes so does he have a move
here
tween age 6 i'll take age 79 air tickets
out that's the cleanest will
and G takes an HT hg 63 f age should win
so
check yep I missed ya I cannot make a
mistake so easy decision let's say okay
here my deep pond must be the should be
the winner let's point forward yeah d7
and Luca vain check black resigns yeah
sorry for for doing this all the time
maybe it's annoying to say that I don't
understand how they can play a move like
that in three seconds of course I mean
it is going to be very dangerous he
allows me this 96 we're not saying that
it is good or anything but it's a very
responsible decision to allow that and
it was played as I said in a split
second yeah I don't know maybe maybe
he's okay it's definitely dangerous and
this is definitely dangerous I mean
which again played in four seconds and
yeah maybe upson sorry maybe taking I
was and then I was thinking g4 here but
I he played it so quickly I couldn't
couldn't really calculate that this is
going to be this is winning and yeah I
wasn't it was only like having the idea
I didn't calculate anything this is the
stuff looks dangerous but far less so
than the game Jackie the game man I mean
this is getting super dangerous yeah the
engine is already saying that I'm
completely winning yes hello shocker but
this wins ok G sound is winning here
this is a i hope this also add this also
wins but g7 ok that was a Miss FG seven
assists of course stronger once you see
that this move is possible you
immediately see how strong it is ok
check check ya know
the point is to turn to going to promote
yeah complicated complicated game and
that's that you can very quickly and in
some critical situations okay well
thanks for watching